une vidéo publiée par le compte echotalk
met en cause un reportage sur le loup
réalisé par Le Figaro accusé de faire du
lobbying dénonçant des mensonges et
renvoie vers une autre vidéo qui promet
selon les auteurs de rétablir la vérité
nous avons bien regardé ces deux vidéos
qui relèvent davantage de l'opinion et
quelques assertions nous ont frappé il
affirme ensuite qu'il y aurait plus de
2000 loups en France alors qu'il y a à
peine 1000 loups en France il a-t-il
vraiment plus de 2000 loups en France
Bruno lecte ne dit à aucun moment dans
notre reportage qu'il y a plus de 2000
loups il donne même le nombre de 1100
loups qui est le recensement officiel de
l'Office français de la biodiversité en
septembre dernier et c'est juste après
que l'éleveur dit qu'il y aurait
peut-être en réalité entre 15500 et 2000
loups en France pourquoi estime-t-il que
ce nombre est peut-être sous-évalué par
l'ofb d'abord parce qu'on ne compte pas
les loups individuellement c'est
impossible leur décompte se fait selon
un modèle mathématique mise en place par
les scientifiques et l'ofb précise bien
qu'il s'agit d'une estimation cette
estimation elle découle de plusieurs
sources donct des analyses génétiques
mais également des observations
réalisées par un réseau de correspondant
de l'ofb spécialement formé pour ça en
2022 par exemple 385 nouveaux
correspondants avaient été recrutés par
l'ofb ce qui avait fait exploser le
nombre d'indices de présence du loup
relevé et faire réestimer bien à la
hausse sa population on peut donc
légitimement se demander si on ne
trouverait pas encore plus de loup si on
mettait encore plus de moyens humains
pour détecter sa présence enfin on peut
préciser qu'en 2017 lorsque les
scientifiques avaient déterminé le seuil
de viabilité du loup en France il
l'avait fixé à 500 individus avaiit
prévu de l'atteindre en 2023 en réalité
ce seuil a été atteint d 2019 soit 4 ans
auparavant ce qui montre bien que les
estimations peuvent être assez bancales
il affirme que l'État veut plus de loup
l'État veut plus de loup qui est
complètement faux le nouveau plan loup
met l'espèce en danger qu'est-ce que le
plan loup et met-il en danger l'espèce
le plan loup c'est un programme de
gestion adopté tous les 5 ans par le
ministère de l'Agriculture après des
discussions avec les associations de
défense des prédateurs avec les éleveurs
avec les scientifiques avec tous les
différents acteurs concernés par la
question et ce plan lou il détermine à
la fois les grandes priorités
scientifiques c'est-à-dire l'observation
de l'espèce pour mieux la connaître mais
également la manière dont on va protéger
l'espèce et la régulation de sa
population et pour réguler cette
population l'état fixe chaque année un
quota de loups qui peuvent être prélevés
qui peuvent être tués et ce quota
correspond à un taux de la population
totale de loup en général ces dernières
années ce cota se situe entre 15 et 20 %
de la population totale de loup ces
politiques de régulation elles sont
motivées par le fait qu'une population
de loup hors de contrôle serait nuisible
et à chaque plan loup les associations
disent craindre que l'espèce ne soit
menacée quand elle ne dénonce pas une
disparition organisée du prédateur en
2012 déjà elles avaient qualifié le plan
loup de véritable plan de chasse et en
2023 pour montrer leur mécontentement
elles ont quitté le groupe national lou
dans lequel discutent les différents
acteurs or malgré ce péril brandi par
les deux youtubeurs et par les
associations la population de Lou ne
cesse de croître de manière
exponentielle chaque année en France
depuis sa réintroduction en 1992 on a
désormais une population de 1100 loups
ce qui est deux fois plus important que
le seuil de viabilité qui avait été fixé
par les scientifiques en 2017 à 500
individus en 2023 209 lou ont été
abatttu dans tout le pays et ce sera
encore pire cette année dans toute
l'Europe une élimination du loup
s'organise 209 loup ont-il été tués en
France en 2023 et y y a-t-il une
élimination du loup qui s'organise
partout en Europe il y a bien environ
209 loups qui ont été tués en France en
2023 pour être précis il y en avait 199
officiellement au 21 décembre mais ce
nombre brandi comme ça n'a aucun sens
puisque comme on l'expliquait ses
prélèvements répondent au quotas fixé
par l'État et si le nombre de
prélèvements est de plus en plus
important c'est parce que la population
du loup est de plus en plus importante
et c'est la même chose partout en Europe
dans tous les pays de l'Union Européenne
le nombre de loups augmente en France en
Italie et en Allemagne il a même doublé
sur la période 2016-2021 seulement le
canidé ne plaît pas à tout le monde en
France le loup est reclassé au Rond
d'ennemi public le loup est-il vraiment
un ennemi public en France alors on
l'oublierait presque à cause du ton
dramatique de ces vidéos mais le loup
est une espèce strictement protégée en
France et en Europe tuer un loup ou
essayer de tuer un loup fait en courir
jusqu'à 3 ans de prison et 150000 €
d'amende donc l'état organise et finance
sa présence et sa protection sur le
territoire d'après les associations
d'éleveurs on estime que le plan loup
coûterait environ 30 millions d'euros
par an à l'État dont environ 90 % pour
financer les moyens de protection des
troupeaux et les 10 % restants pour
indemniser les éleveurs qui ont été
attaqués par le loup alors ça ne prend
pas en compte le coût du suivi de
l'espèce le coût de son recensement et
cetera mais on est déjà à 45000 € par
loup et par an alors pour être honnête
on peut préciser que l'Union européenne
se penche actuellement sur une révision
du statut de protection du loup Ursula
van derleon pousse d'ailleurs en
personne ce dossier après qu'un de C
Ponet a été attaqué par lou l'été
dernier pourquoi cette révision et bien
justement parce qu'on estime que sa
population et que sa viabilité ne
nécessite plus un aussi haut niveau de
protection mais cette révision non
seulement elle n'est pas acquise elle
pourrait prendre plusieurs années et le
loup surtout continuera d'être protégé
même s'il n'est plus strictement protégé
il faut tout de même reconnaître que le
loup a bien des ennemis en France
notamment des éleveurs nombre d'entre
eux ont constaté l'inefficacité des
moyens de protection qu'on leur
promettait et sont traumatisés par les
attaques dans un rapport de 2020 lin
raer rappelait tout de même que 90 % des
attaques de loup réussi dans les Alpes
l'était sur des troupeaux protégés par
les moyens préconisés dire que le loup
est un ennemi public en France c'est nié
ce qui a été mis en place et ce qui
continue d'être mis en place pour
assurer sa présence toujours plus
nombreuse sur le territoire français
coupable du seul crime d'exister et de
ces quelques visites dans le garde
manger de l'homme tutons des loups juste
pour quelques visites dans le garde
manger de l'homme les vidéastes
utilisent volontairement une formule
candide pour nous attendrir sur le sort
du loup mais en réalité les visite dans
le garde manger de l'homme c'est pas
Milou qui va dérober quelques saucisses
au boucher du coin ce sont des brebis
des chèvres des même désormais qui sont
égorgé éventré qui avortent parce
qu'elles sont profondément traumatisées
par les attaques ou qui meurent de chute
dans le vide parce qu'elles sont
épouvanté par le prédateur et pour
l'homme pour le berger c'est la crainte
perpétuelle de retrouver ses bêtes
massacrées en estive de devoir les
ramasser de les compter de se battre
avec l'administration pour faire
reconnaître ses dégâts et c'est un
traumatisme parce qu'il perd à la fois
les animaux auxquels il est évidemment
attaché mais également la raison même
pour laquelle il
[Musique]
travaille